翻訳: Kumika Moore
校正: Riaki Poništ
私は数年前までライターをしてました
だから 言葉を使って表現することは得意です
でも最近は 言葉を使わないで
メッセージを伝える―
そのことに夢中になってます
言葉を使わないでメッセージを
届ける方法はたくさんあります
写真、動画、音楽もそうですよね？
それから ジェスチャー、ダンス
そして ファッション
「装い」も 言葉を使わないで
メッセージを伝える手段です
今日の私の装い―
（笑）
（拍手）
単に目立ちたがり屋で赤を着ているわけでは
なかったってことです
（笑）
ご覧のように「赤べこ」というのは
福島の代表的なマスコットで
会津が発祥の地です
その会津に尊敬の意を込めて
そして「私は福島を本気でPRしているよ」
というメッセージなんです
伝わりましたでしょうか？
（拍手）
先日 福島で
「ファッショナブルふくしま」という
ちょっと変わったファッションショーを
友人のスタイリストと一緒に開催しました
これは福島の魅力—
特産物や観光地
そういったものを
ファッションで表現しようという
ちょっと変わった試みなんです
登場してくれたのは
一般市民の人たちです
一般市民の人たちが
例えば 福島競馬場、それから桃
それから土湯こけし、もちろん赤べこ
そういったものをファッションで
表現して ランウェイを歩いてもらいました
一番人気だったのが こちらです
（笑）
ご存知の方 多いと思いますが—
福島の方は—
でも 知らない人は多いと思います
「いかにんじん」です
福島の郷土料理なんです
これは人参の細切り それから
スルメイカの細切りを醤油で和えた—
とても素朴です
でも とっても美味しい
美味しいんですけれども
ちょっと地味なんですよね
これを華やかに発信するには
どうしたらいいか
人参のオレンジ色、イカの茶色、
そして この細切りの形状
これをファッションで表すと―
おっ
（感嘆）
これは福島市に住む
中学生のサトウさんですが
こんな風に お母さんと
「いかにんじんファッション」で
ランウェイを
（音楽）
歩いてもらいました
（音楽終わり）
かわいいでしょ？
（笑）
「いかにんじん」のように
地域では愛されているけれども
外に広がっていないものは
たくさんあります
そういうものも
ちょっと表現方法を変えるだけで
たくさんの人に見ていただく
チャンスが生まれます
そして「いかにんじん 食べてみたい」
そう思う人もいるでしょう
実際に食べてほしいです
本当に美味しいんです
地域の魅力を
いろんな表現方法で発信する
その方が伝わりやすい
そういうふうに思い始めた
あるきっかけがありました
それは２年前です
私はその半年前に
長年住んだ東京から
故郷の福島に戻ってきました
福島は東日本大震災から
第一原発の事故があって
復興に向けて進んでいました
そして 私が住む福島市をはじめ
ほとんどの所では
安全に普通の暮らしをしていました
でも とても誤解されていました
「福島では未だに—
未だにマスクをしないと歩けない」
私の友人ですら
そんなふうに思っている人がいました
この誤解を解きたい
そこで動画を作ったんです
当時 ファレル・ウィリアムスの『Happy』
という曲が大ヒットしていました
そして同時に この曲に合わせて
ハッピーなダンスを踊る
それを動画に撮る
これも流行っていました
世界中のいろんな地域 いろんな町で
「ご当地ハッピー」が作られました
それを見て
「そうだ 福島版のハッピーを作ろう」
そう思いました
そして 周りの人に声を掛けて
協力してもらって
ダンスを踊ってもらいました
みんな快く協力してくれました
[FUKUSHIMA]
[IS ALSO]
[HAPPY]
駅長さんや市長さん
それからお店の店主さん、学生
旅館の女将さん
そういう普通の人が
楽しそうに踊る動画でした
みんな本当に いい笑顔で
踊ってくれたおかげで
それから
「あの福島がハッピーダンスを踊っている」
そういう話題性もあって
動画は たくさんの人にシェアをされて
なんと100万回も再生されました
そして驚いたのは 世界中からたくさん
コメントが寄せられたんです
「えっ 福島ってこんなふうなの？」
（笑）
そう 赤べこにも踊ってもらったんですけど
「え 福島ってこんなふうなの？」
「なんか すごくいいよねぇ」
「行ってみたい」
「きれいな所だね」「頑張ってね」
ほんとに いろんな国から
コメントが寄せられたんです
私はそれを見て
「福島の元気を伝えられた」
それは言葉では
たぶん難しかったと思う
ダンス、みんなの表情
それを動画で発信したから
たくさんの人が見てくれた
そういうふうに思いました
それから どういうふうに地域の魅力を
表現したら良いのか
いつも考えていました
悩むこともありました
時には まったく違う文化の人が
その表現方法をよく知っていることがあります
彼らは海外から来た留学生です
「Go Go Tohoku」という
プロジェクトがあります
これは 仙台の大学で学んでいる
海外からの留学生が
東北の魅力をソーシャルメディアで発信する
というプロジェクトです
100人くらい「東北アンバサダー」
と呼ばれる学生たちがいます
そのうちの５人が 先日
福島にやってきてくれました
私は彼らを案内してどんなふうに
発信するのかなというのを見ていました
とても面白かったです
ちょっと紹介します
これは 喜多方市にある
会津電力の雄国発電所です
ご覧のように メガソーラー
これでクリーンなエネルギーを発電しています
私は ここに何度も行きましたが
たしかに素晴らしい景色の所だけれども
このメガソーラー自体は無機質で
あまり美しいとは思えなかった
でも彼らを案内した時
ちょうど夕暮れでした
夕日がこのソーラーに反射して
とても美しかったんです
すると彼らは
こんなことを始めました
（カメラのシャッター音）
このソーラーの前でジャンプを―
お互いにジャンプをしながら
写真を撮り合うんです
すると こんな写真が出来上がりました
（笑）
まったく別の場所のようです
何か未来を感じました
それから やはり喜多方市の
三ノ倉というとこの
ひまわり畑に行きました
ここは250万本もの ひまわりが植えられて
観光名所になっています
みんな このひまわりの前で
記念写真を撮るんです
こんな風に
（笑）
これは私です
自分の記録としては いいけれども
これは広まる写真ではありません
そこで フィリピンから来たゴウくんと
ロシアから来たキーアちゃんが
お互いに協力しながら このひまわり畑で
写真を撮っていました
こんな感じです
（笑）
全身で表してますね
それから
これはゴウくんが撮った写真ですけど
キーアさんは髪がピンク色で
このひまわりの黄色と とてもマッチして
動きのある写真ですよね？
表現方法は たくさんあります
でも まず始めなければなりませんよね？
この方は サトウさんといって
会津若松市に住む 製造業を営む方です
サトウさんは 私のソーシャルメディアの
講座に来てくれました
課題がありました
「身の回りの物を動画に撮って
フェイスブックに投稿してください」
そういう課題でした
サトウさんは そんなことは
やったことはありません
で ご覧のように 鮎釣りが趣味の方です
サトウさんが投稿した動画は
こんなふうでした
ビデオ：（環境音）
（サトウさん）ハリも付けます
付けたので これから
鮎釣りをしたいと思います
まず第一投 釣れますように
お願いします
ゴー！
来た 来た 来た
でかいよ でかいよ
でかいよ
あぶねぇ あぶねぇ
あぶねぇ
溺れる 溺れる
ヒュー
でかいよ でかいよー
来た 来た 来た 来た
うおぉ
やっと来たよ 一匹
おぉ
あぶねぇ あぶねぇ
おおっ
足場がね わりぃんだよ
フー！
来た 来た 来た
さあ 釣れました 一匹
これが先ほどのオトリ合いで
その下に これが掛かり合いですね
やっぱりこの時期になると結構
型も大きくて 美味しそうな鮎ですね
いやぁ やっと釣れました
こんな所で釣ってきました
（熊坂仁美）こんな感じです
サトウさんは片手でスマートフォン
片手で鮎を持って
スマートフォンが 水没しそうになりながら
頑張って撮ったそうです
で 感想を聞くと
「私 訛ってるんですね」って
（笑）
これが感想でした
とても美しい所ですよね？
私 釣りはやらないんですけど
行ってみたくなりました
ここは南会津の伊南川という所です
鮎釣りのメッカだそうです
でも 私は知りませんでした
こんな所があるなんて
たぶん鮎釣りの人は
すごく知っている
そして 地域の人は
よく知っている
だから「 みんな知ってるんだ」と
サトウさんも思っていました
でも 知りません
知らない人 多いですよね？
たぶん全国でも
ほとんど知られてません
これは どうしてですか？
情報発信をしていないんじゃ
ないでしょうか？
今 地方は どんどん人口が
減少しています
産業がなくて
若者が外に出ています
観光客も なかなか
やって来てくれません
みんな言います
「田舎は何にもないから」
「うちの周りには何にもないから」
でも 本当でしょうか？
気が付いていないだけ
じゃないでしょうか？
そして 発信をしていないだけ
スマートフォンを持っている人は
多いと思います
スマートフォンで何をしますか？
もしかしたら「情報を受け取るだけ」の
モノになっていませんか？
もしそうだとしたら
使い方が間違っています
少なくとも都会ならいいです
少なくとも 地方で「活性化したい」
そう思っている地方の人たちなら
スマートフォンは
「発信するため」のモノです
何も難しいことは要らないんです
サトウさんみたいに
身の回りの物を発信するだけでいい
そして サトウさんみたいな人が
５人、10人、そして100人いたら
変わると思いませんか？
地域にとって情報発信は
とてもとても大事です
まず知ってもらわなければいけない
それにはスマートフォンを―
何度も言います
スマートフォンは
「発信するため」のモノです
一緒に発信しましょう
ありがとうございました
（拍手）